hello and welcome to this video playing
at FGM Julian Hodgson so what do we get
here mr. tech GM should have played
before I don't know a place a modern
right now so let's see what we get here
I think you play some Bishop c5 stuff
Bishop divorce what he played against me
in an earlier game I remember correctly
that was a that was a funny line yeah
isn't that a funny move so okay um I
don't quite remember how that went
Knight f3 cannot possibly bad it's
probably also nothing special maybe just
be three I don't know it's really a
strange move so the check I know he
takes that interesting ok I would assume
that this shouldn't be bad for me that
blocked center with the potential for f4
he probably will play a quickie 98 @ f 5
himself those positions tend to be quite
easy for black to play so this is what I
expect yeah so he goes for a five okay
not much that I can do about it and I
also don't need you frankly it's just
what what happens here nothing
particularly frightening maybe I should
have played hookie one actually huh ok
so i can still flick that in ok so
what's going on here night again sorry
27 and potentially Bishop h3 is what you
probably wants to do okay if I go h3
king and
eh true I don't know a little bit
uncertain but yeah so here what is he
going to do is he going to i can go g
for an airflow in this position that's
actually interesting let's do it i mean
i didn't really check it in detail but I
don't see a sacrifice walking here that
would be quite weird so I now f4 is
there some direct way of refuting this
just no clog and this should be good
right that looks like it did a decent
position for me so I put the night to d5
or a first-person normal move I don't
know maybe I should have played 95
because of this yes I was just thinking
about it but still still yeah but where
is he going with all this going here
bishop g6 maybe a sense idea hmm ok I
wanted to put the bishop here anyway so
let's do it
and central noise not sure I'm 3
threatening to take only five maybe I do
my pic takes okay he basically says okay
I'm threatening it so let's go see you
form and go from yourself am i able to
do some something here Bishop b4 to f5
isn't is an active idea that I want to
try and potentially go all the way to e6
okay so he's going back it's that
technically I don't see it so maybe
activate even more oh we should be six I
wanted to play wookie 5 which doesn't
work but I can take I can take the
bishop okay at least that's not going to
be terrible so that didn't see this
correctly this smooth not quite sure
what I'm threatening it may be a look at
one next ok I'm going to take the
scissors may be debatable but I feel
that this should be a little bit better
for me yeah takes must be a slightly
favorable structure structure at least I
know a queen bee for maybe I'm not
threatening to take though
[Music]
I'm sure it's got a really high rating
I'm in mask again service is great minus
three I mean as my I spoiled some
extremely good positions that's what I
remember so I should be alert not to
fall into some swindle or whatever I
mean I'm not I'm not clearly better you
anything I just said I feel I'm not
worse and I shouldn't shouldn't blunder
course you never should but it's kind of
I've been burned before so if i play he
has CSS checky available it says
something active here that I can do it's
not quite clear if I have something
[Music]
maybe you just like put the King on g2
safely and not i mean just prevent a
check it also easy for him to improve
his pieces further at least a nice i
don't see it oopsie several yeah you can
do that this one name I could have gone
look at five maybe
[Music]
maybe I can just run the h-bomb I'm not
trading Queens thats it's basically out
of the question not with my king being
the Savior one here now g5 HF is a
poison idea he will probably trade a
look that makes sense for black yeah
that definitely makes sense so okay I'm
going back that's that's fine check yeah
so King takes on is checking them I
can't take with the rook cannot take a
three because of queen is six and I
wonder ever have some idea here
connected with the deep horn it's still
a bit easier for me to play this
position d 676 maybe d6 Queen 27
probably time morning
[Music]
interesting move is he actually
counter-attacking somehow i don't see it
so check let's take good check check i
wonder if i can summer win but my king
is just so open and it feels very
unlikely that the check should work so i
probably gently with the draw him draw
our third game rocking is far too open I
mean that deep on passer looks good but
it doesn't feel like I can win the
computer wants me to play on but yeah
maybe I had something that that's
actually quite likely the position after
f4 should be better for white and the
engine disagree with this I probably
should play 95 now and this this was
done at a too hasty this is keeping this
night out makes it more difficult for
him it's just an open position where
I've got more space and the bishop pan
so it should be a little bit better for
white ok what I got also was nice
without any question ok Bishop takes a 7
I didn't think about that one just take
the pawn and sometimes just overlook
those simple things it's not bad just
grab the pond but I think in general way
I played it cannot be that bad we should
be for was better be sure before again
and now I did not play Bishop f5 for
whatever reason hmm rookie three yeah of
course I mean white must be bit better
here but I don't know how substantial it
is he is fairly solid here with all
these pawns on dark squares and the line
Bishop I mean I also had something here
at it maybe wasn't enough J g5
immediately must was maybe a bit more
testing and then this is stop vicious is
certainly right with this assessment it
is a little bit more than a slight edge
but it's not something that should
ultimately Jenny probably check their
the chatting fields I can do something
here with moves like a for it now I
don't I don't believe it is probably so
lucky to end in a draw with my bad King
ok guys thanks for watching